okay jay you're now live thank you very
much tom
well it's time to start now isn't it i
think yep
well good evening uh fellow councillors
and
public following our council meeting of
the 22nd of february
full council meeting budget special
those of you following on youtube
so we start first of all with apologies
for absence
or we do the register first shall we um
sandra is it sandra it's mary ann kirsty
tonight so
is kirsty doing the register chair oh
thank you kirsten
if you do the register first thank you
chair
councillor belton yeah i'm here
councillor brenton president councillor
bright
yeah councillor brown president
councillor bushby president councillor
christie
president councillor clark
yeah councillor dart
present councillor ford
councillor harding president councillor
hawkins
yeah here councillor heppel
no not present okay thanks tom
councillor hicks
president councillor hudson president
councillor hurley president councillor
hutchings
yep councillor inch
thank you councillor james president
councillor jones yeah councillor
langford
present council of laws present
councillor leather yeah councillor locke
president councillor manly president
councillor mcguff i'm here
councilor mckenzie president
councillor newton president councillor
pennington
councillor rossie president councillor
watson
brandon councillor wiseman i'm here
thank you usd councillor ford's now
arrived
oh thanks tom right thank you for that
now we have apologies for absence then
there are no apologies chair all right
thank you so we go
to item two then public contributions i
understand there's two people wish you
to speak
that's correct yeah okay so uh
you've got your uh three minutes end
please
keely allen first thank you very much
um the town council has been asked to
comment on the motions put forward by
councillors bright and cottle hunken
members of great toronton town council
would urge torres district council to
either keep the charges the same as last
year
if only for this one year of what is
hoped to be a year of retail recovery in
the small market towns
or if that is absolutely impossible to
keep the same level of fee for at least
two hours
economically speaking the retail trade
has been through an unprecedented year
of difficulty
which has seen non-essential shops
closed for three separate lockdown
periods for approximately six out of the
twelve months
if the current lockdown extends to the
end of march there is much hope that
once restrictions are lifted
there will be an upsurge in spending
locally and this will be helped
massively by low parking charges
thank you thank you very much indeed
you're the mayor aren't you thank you um
and who's the second person
it's karen the town clerk for great
torrington thank you
thank you it's okay chair um cancer alan
has
um relayed the message thank you very
much okay
thank you very much indeed yeah can i
just let you know
councillor heppel's now joined the
meeting
right so that's the public contributions
as as you know those uh items will be
discussed later on so now we go to
declarations of interest well
councillors you who know what the rules
and regulations are
so uh and obviously you will abide by
them
um item four then agreement between part
one and two there are no
part two items uh this evening so
go on to item five correspondence by
myself
uh i have none um steve is there
anything that's cropped up since i last
spoke to you
i'm sure there's nothing else nothing
else okay
so we go straight into into the main
item uh
the budget item six and uh
the officers will lead on that thank you
um thank you kirsty could you get the
presentation ready to
go through please okay
so um apologies in advance for members
of internal overview and scrutiny and
community and resources have already
seen this presentation
um before and any other members who
watched however those two committees
it's largely the same presentation with
some
minor tweaks so what am i going to cover
tonight i'm going to cover the impact
team i'm going to have a refresh on
where the council actually gets its
funding from
i'm going to talk about the 2021-22
local government settlement
i'll discuss some key themes and
assumptions we'll discuss the council's
capital programme
i'll alert members to the risk and
uncertainties in the budget projections
that i'll be presenting
where are we now and the recommendations
could have the next slide please kirsty
so
well kovit 19 has been an exceptional
year for our local authorities
including torridge our income from fees
and charges has been hit by the
various national lockdowns in particular
car parking we're currently estimating
that our car parking income will be down
six hundred thousand pounds
in the current financial year and that
compares to a budget of one point three
million so nearly fifty percent
um conversely other income has strangely
enough has been shouted out particularly
planning
some of our income which has been
sharply down is the money that we get
from our short-term treasury deposit
because of the
bank of england's base rate cut at the
start of the pandemic so we're
forecasting that's down 125 000 pounds
we've also been tasked with the deals
with various transits of government
support grants
such as business support grants track
and trace self-isolation payments for
individuals
and also hardship grants the council's
also incurred additional expenditure
during the current financial years of
just additional ppe
cleaning i.t investment to facilitate
homework in the
majority of our office-based staff
actually now currently working from home
increased support for legend members
will be aware of many meetings we've had
about that
and um admin burdens pertaining to the
delivery of the various
governments of grants that we've had to
administer have the next slide please
kirsten
so just how unusual has it been
i'm predicting that this year this
council will spend
in addition um in a in advance of 60
million pounds
in a normal year excluding housing
benefit payments we've
incurred about 16 million pounds of
gross expenses that gives you the scale
of the actual expenditure the council
has incurred supporting the government's
initiative to mitigate the effects of
the pandemic
okay have the next slide please kirsty
in recognition of the impact that kovid
19 has had on the finances of local
authorities central government has
provided additional support
we've had some additional coveted
expenses programs 1.2 million
we've had new burdens recognizing we've
got additional responsibilities such as
paying the business support
grant paying the self-isolation payments
and the hardship payments
and there's a scheme for lost fees and
charges
and we're expected to get 1.2 million
for the expenses support grants
just under a third of a million for the
new burdens and just over a third of a
million for the lost fees and charges
which is compensation for the
lost car parking income amongst others
that we've lost
and however we're still projecting a
surplus as a quarter to 642
000 pounds which will be earmarked to
support the council's capital program
where we have a funding deficit
and there's a variety of contributing
factors to why we're under spending
um additional responsibilities in terms
of like administering the business
support grants have largely been
absorbed by our existing staff there has
been some overtime
but we haven't employed additional stuff
to do the work
there's been a low incidence of covered
with intelligence i think with the
lowest within
england which has meant we've had
relatively modest backfilling of our
front line staff
in like refuge for example and whilst we
lost a lot of parking in particular in
the first three months of the
national lot down during the summer with
the staycation people being unable to
travel abroad for the holidays
and parking income did bounce back and
it has been an exceptional year for
planning income
exceptional we're over 400 grand above
target maybe we might even top a little
bit more than that
and that's against a budget of 540 so
we've nearly doubled
the budget for planning income and the
council has been prudent in its use of
resources and particularly how we
support our partners our leisure
provider
1610. have the next slide please kirsty
i think i've heard this air comes to all
parts of life it's easy to forget
with all things covered that normal life
still has to function
and so the council still needs to
deliver its value services to its
resident and also raise the revenue to
fund these services you know
we've still got to collect the waste
we've still got to clean the streets we
still have parks and open spaces that we
have to maintain
public conveniences leisure we'll still
need to collect the council tax on
business rates process housing benefit
claims
in may run an election cemeteries food
hygiene
process planning applications building
control i could name more so we still
have to recognize that we've got to
continue to do the day job
next slide please kirsty
okay so on the left there you've got a
pie chart which shows the
where the council gets its money from
and if you can see the two largest
components in blue are fees and charges
and in red
council tax and central government
grants ignoring the additional covert
grants we've had this year
only account for 10 11 of the council's
revenue
the little box to the right hand side
with the lines shows the trend
on the council's sources of income and
if you see the thick line the thicker
line
that is central government grant so
that's in long-term decline so in
essence the council
survives on the money it generates from
business rates council tax and fees and
charges and
increasingly central government grant is
less important than it once was
income from fees and charges and council
tax are both the
two biggest components of our funding
but also the areas where members
decisions directly impact upon the
revenue the council can generate
thank you kirsty netslide please
and the local government settlement the
headline figure members may have heard
is that core spending power for local
authority sector increased by 4.5
for torridge this is officially actually
zero percent and in reality we've
actually had a small decline in our um
core spending power because of a reduced
reduction to our council tax base
85 of the increase in the core spending
power the central government announced
actually relates to councils increasing
their council tax up to
their referendum limits so just for
to recap what does core spending power
consist of well it consists of revenue
support grant
the rural services delivery grant which
we get in tourists for a very rural
community and it recognizes
more expensive to operate services like
refuge
retain business rate income and their
associated section 31 grants
new homes bonus income a new grant
called the lower
services lower tier services grant
social care grants which aren't
applicable to
torridge as we're a lower tier authority
we don't have social care responsibility
and council tax
income next slide please
okay so excluding the kovid 19 funding
that we will receive
for 2020-21 mainstream central
government grant funding for torah will
actually decline by 183 000 pounds in
the next financial year
and you can see some pie charts there so
revenue support grant
next year is basically the same as the
current financial year
there's a modest increase in the rural
services delivery grant
and the big one there if you see new
homes bonus well that's fallen
dramatically from 924 000 to 381
000 the lower services tier grant and
that's a new one we didn't get that last
year that's 297
000. part of that is compensation to
ensure that we
um our core spending power doesn't reach
zero percent
and we've had a small increase in our
homelessness grant
so put simply without an increase in the
council tax up to the
council tax referendum limit todrick
would see a significant decline in its
core spending power
mainly because our core grants have
declined by 183 000 pounds
next slide please um kirsty
so um there's the pie chart the chart so
the chart that you can see has various
different colors
and essentially our preceptors have
different referendum limits than
ourselves so for devon county council
they're allowed to put it by two percent
plus three percent for their social care
precepts they've actually put it by one
point nine
nine percent devon and cornwall police
were allowed to put
their council tax up by 15 pounds for a
bandy equivalent
which equates to 6.8 percent i believe
they put it up by 14 pound 92.
um devon and somerset 5 they could put
their
precept up by 2 i think they did 1.99
percent and we can put it by five pound
per pan d
which equates to two point nine six
percent and there is no referendum
limits for our parish and town councils
and what the bar chart shows that at the
time i
um did these these slides i estimated
that a bandy
equivalent within turf would rise by 95
pounds and six pence it'll
still actually will rise from slightly
less than that but
however very marginally less it's
authority's share of that
is five pound that's the yellow bar that
you can see
so you can see that actually we will
contribute a very very small percentage
of the actual
increase in the council tax that our
residents will bear next flag please
kirsty
it whilst we it's our name on the bill
as a billing of foster when the bills go
out it'll have tori's district council
at the head
but our share of the council tax has
been in long-term decline and that's
because the county has been able to do
a social care preset for the last few
years and also that the police have had
above
inflation um rises in their precept and
the town and paris councils
and they've not had any referendum and
many of their times they've
raised their um presets above inflation
so as you can see there we're in
long-term decline
so actually we'll only take tories we
only take eight and a half percent of
the council tax that's actually
collected
next slide please sir kirsten
it's just so members are aware the
assumption we have the medium term
financial strategies the council will
increase its council tax up to the
referendum really in each year
of the medium-term financial strategy
whilst council is required to report
their tax base in bandy equivalents and
any increases in council tax are
referenced to bandy amount it should be
recognized that the majority of
residents within torridge actually live
in properties
within bands a to c 68 so therefore
they'd actually pay less than the five
pound
extra per year a council tax increase of
five pound per band d equivalent equates
to less than 10 pence a week for 85
percent of our residents that's those
who live in bands
a to d next slide please
in previous years members made the
decision not to increase the council tax
and in those years
central government offered some um
council as compensation some council tax
freeze grants but they were
non-recurrent in nature
and the graph shows the impact of not
raising the council tax in prior years
in line with the referendum limits
for torres the decision not to raise the
council tax in prior years has had a
cumulative effect of over three million
pounds so we've collected three million
pounds less
over since 2010-11 because we haven't
raised the council
on on an annual basis now we're about
440
000 pounds per year we collect less
because we didn't raise the council tax
in previous years
because of the referendum limits the
council simply cannot claw back that
council tax income foregone
in prior years and what that chart shows
is that there's a
long-term impact of not raising the
council tax it's not a one-year wonder
it lives with the council for forever
basically uh next slide please tom
kirsten apologies so what am i some of
the key assumptions
generally in normal times the council
tax collection
rate for torridge is very high it's
normally 98.5
to 99 with really modest changes from
year to year
the protection collection rate for 2020
2020-21 the current year is 96.5
and we're projecting a collection rate
for next year of 97.4
5 due to the impact of coverage with
people perhaps being on furlough and
having reduced incomes
and we're projecting that the collection
rate will increase by 0.5 percent each
year until 2024
25 when the collection rates forecast to
be back to 98.95
um on business rates been a very unusual
near
year for business rates um for the
council
in reaction to the coverage pandemic
central government announced various
business rate lease most notably retail
relief so as a consequence the amount of
business rates the council actually
collected in 2020
21 declined from 12 million to four and
a half million
we were compensated by um grants from
government for
collecting less business rates i'm at
the time of writing this report
there's been no announcement as yet on
the business rate
reliefs that may be awarded for 2021-22
however central governments indicated
that we should hold
off raising our business rate bills to
after the budget which i believe is on
the third of march
so that would indicate to me that there
will be some additional
ongoing business rate relief offered to
businesses as part of the government's
reaction to the pandemic
so over the medium-term financial
strategy avitsu
assumed a very modest increase in the
collectible business rate over the life
of the medium-term financial strategy
next slide please kirsty
some other key assumptions i've assumed
that the income from our short-term
treasury deposits
will remain low because of the bank of
england base rate and i'm not in
anticipating the interest rates will
return to their pre-covered 19 levels
until
the financial year 2025-26
i've also assumed that the income from
our fees and charges
will be at their 2020-21 budgeted levels
excluding car parking and garden wage
which we'll come to later
however the ongoing impacts of kovid 19
and our fees and charges income is
unknown
the government comp the government's
compensation scheme for loss fees and
charges has been extended to june 2021
so we will receive 75 pence in the pound
for any fees and charges income
that was below budget in the first three
months of the next financial year
next slide please kirsten
so one of the other key assumptions is
the chancellor announced that there
would be a freeze on public sector pay
with the exception of the nhs
um technically local authorities are not
part of the public sector
for pay negotiations however central
government in its settlement to
local authorities provided no money for
pay awards and generally one would
expect that the local
government association would follow to
some degree central government
guidelines
on public sector pay so i have assumed
in our
budgets going forward that there'll be
no pay award this year
except for staff who are on less than 24
000 pounds for an animal get a 250 pound
increase
i've assumed for 2023 20
three 2022 percent increase two thousand
twenty three twenty four one point five
percent increase
two thousand twenty four twenty five a
two percent increase
however just to give some context the
unions have recently put a play claim in
for two thousand twenty one twenty two
and just some highlights from the
union's pay claim a ten percent uplift
for all salaries
a reduction in the working week to 35
hours
a minimum of 25 days annually and the
introduction of a home working allowance
um very rough modeling of that for
torrids would be that would cost us over
one million pounds
per year and next slide please
um it's i have to recognize that i think
we all recognize that leisure has been
particularly badly hit by kovid 19 and
we'll face significant challenges going
forward
it's difficult to ascertain how long the
kovic 19 restrictions will be in place
and to what extent our customers will
return to our leisure facilities
consequently an additional 150 thousand
pounds per annum has been included
within the
budgets to reflect an estimate of the
additional cost of providing our leisure
facilities
next slide please
okay so where are we after accounting
for the pressures i've just alluded to
um obviously we've seen a big reduction
in our new homes bonus funding
we've got um funding we need for the
environmental sensor
we'll come to that later in the
catalogue we've got ongoing capital
pressures that we've recognized which
i'll discuss at some depth later on in
the of 180
we've lost that income from our
short-term treasury deposit because of
the bank of england base rate cut
and we're anticipating increased costs
of providing leisure
so the advised
deficits i'm forecasting and they're
compared with the deficits i reported at
this time
last year in red so quite clearly you
can see that the position
has worsened next flyer please kirsty
um the council has a transition in
government funding reserve and we use
this reserve to balance our revenue
budgets until such times we've either
found additional
expenditure savings or additional
sources of income
and the projected use of this reserve
based on the deficits from the previous
slide are shown below
and as you can see as the deficit
increase we actually run
out of that reserve it gets exhausted
during 2023-24
next slide please
okay um i now need to move on to capital
and this catholic is a big pressure for
this council
so the council has an approved capital
program at 23 million and there's
currently a deficit 2.2 million
before we take into account new capital
projects
and address some of the funding issues
pertaining to the proposed environmental
center
so there's a little bar chart there
below so the capital program is 23
million
the net bar says shows 7.7 million
that's the money we've actually got
banked for our capital program that's
actually held in capital receipts our
capital reserves
then we're anticipating another eight
million pounds of forecast contributions
so for example we put over half a
million pounds away every year to fund
our vehicle replacement program
we've also got some approved borrowing
of five million pounds
and then we're still leaders with a gap
of 2.1 million pounds
next slide please
so why do we have such a funding gap
well there's a
variety of contributing factors there's
a construction industry build inflation
is a factor so we have a
a project we've set aside money for the
capital program but by the time we get
round to
being able to deliver it inflation is at
into the
program but one of the massive big
factors we've had is the decline in our
new homes bonus funding traditionally
we've amount 50
of our new homes bonus funding for
capital the chart below
shows that at its peak in 2016 2016-17
new homes bonus contributed one million
pounds to the capital programme
if you look at 2021-22 and 2022-23
quickly that's contributing enough into
the capital programme so we've
essentially from 2016
we're now at 1 million pounds a year
worse off
in terms of putting money aside into our
capital program and that needs to be
addressed
next slide please
so the next chart just shows how the gap
that we started the year with 2.2
million has actually risen to
5.7 million so we started off with a gap
of 2.2 million
we recognize that we need to have a
rolling program of putting money aside
every year to fund our capital programme
and we estimate that'll be over the next
five years 900 thousand pounds that's
for
renewing our car parts and our other
assets
just for information the value of the
council's land and property portfolio as
per our audit accounts is 38 million
pounds so we have quite an extensive
property portfolio that we need to
maintain
so that's what that 900 thousand pound
is being
set aside for we have a leisure
contingency of 350 thousand we recognize
that before we
retender the contract for our leisure
services
this works that maybe need to be done so
we set aside a contingency of 350 000
pounds
and the environmental center we've got
increased costs of 1.5 million pounds
and the town hall where i'm sat today
we've got issues with the roof and we
estimate that at just about three
quarters of a million so that
shows how the gap has risen from 2.2
million to 5.7 million pounds
next slide please
okay so how are we going to bridge this
funding gap on the capital programme
well we're breaking it down into three
parts so
we'll how would we approach the gap of
the approved capital program
and some pacific and pid which are
project initiation documents
so we had a balance brought forward of
2.2 million
if we had the leisure contingency in the
town hall roof that gives us 3.3 million
the environmental center has got
increased costs of 1.5 million
and the rolling programmer works which
is money we need to set aside every year
to maintain our existing property
portfolio it's 900 thousand pounds so
club the next flyer please kirsten
so on the first one how are we going to
bridge the shortfall of three point just
under 3.3 million which is our existing
shortfall and then add in
the um leisure contingency
and the town hall roof well there's some
savings in the existing capital program
so we estimate the savings in the
borough centre just over
half a million pounds and there's some
of them minor savings elsewhere within
the program 144 000.
we are also anticipating some capital
receipts now the timing of them
is not known in all cases so we've got
cleave wood capital receipt
tad worthy bridge buildings westford
which we've actually just we have
received
and there's a we've put aside there a
bit of a contingency for
maybe we might not remake all those
capital receipts and also in the future
some new capital programs projects may
arise so we've
knocked off 500 000 pounds from that we
will be contributing
um this year's surplus as as that per
quarter to a 642 000 pounds and the
contribution from next year's budget 275
from the revenue budgets and basically
we can bridge that gap
so next slide please
okay so we've got increased costs of the
environmental center
of 1.5 million well that represents
increased borrowing
is there any chance you can make the
slide ever so slightly bigger at all
kirsty
no thank you
okay thank you uh so therefore
the borrowing for the center is funded
from increased income and cost savings
so so we need to borrow
5.6 million to fund the environmental
center that gives us an annual cost of
382 000
however there are savings from having an
environmental center and they're from
sale increased sales of recycling
materials that we'd be able to process
and get an extra more money from the
market for so it gives us an additional
cost per year
of 170 000 pounds to fund the
environmental center
so that is the difference between the
additional borrowing costs
and the income that we can generate from
selling recycling materials that's what
170
000 represents we've worked out an
increase of five pound per year to the
garden waste charge over the next three
years would generate 180 000 pounds per
year extra
by 2023 24.
cnr on the 25th of january approved
these increased garden waste charges
next slide please kirsten
as i alluded to earlier on the council
has a property portfolio
of 38 million pounds we recognize that
we need to set aside monies
from our revenue into our capital
program to maintain our existing
portfolio and that's what the 900
thousand pounds is over the next five
years which equates to 180
000 pounds a year um one way we could do
this
is by increasing our car parking charges
and there's a little table showing how
these car parties charges staggered over
three years will generate additional
revenue
cnr on the 25th of january approved
these increased car parking charges
netslide please
okay so where are we after cnr's
approval
of the polls increases to fees and
charges the garden waste in the car
parking out as outlined in the capital
report well
the blue chart a colleague of mine has
just poured me some water because i'm
losing my advice thank you very much
the blue chart shows the revised deficit
compared with this time last year and as
you can see now
with those increased charges which were
approved by community and resources
the revenue budgets actually come back
into balance by 2024-25
and the transition in government funding
reserve which is the reserve we do to
balance the budgets and so sort of
sounds we can find savings or increase
revenue
we see that that's maintained we don't
exhaust it with the previous example
that was exhausted by 2023-24 and now
we've actually got a balance to deal
with the
uncertainties in government funding that
i'll allude to later on
next slide please
okay so does this hey i'm just going to
show what would be the impact if we
didn't increase council tax tonight
well in yellow would be the impact of
not increasing council tax tonight
and as you can see the revenue budgets
never actually
get back into balance and the transition
in government funding reserve
is actually run down over the life of
the
medium-term financial strategy uh next
slide please
i now want to talk about risk and
uncertainties we're looking here at the
median term financial strategy up to the
year 2025-26
which is quite clearly a long time into
the future
due to both brexit and the kovid 19
pandemic
reform of local government finances has
been delayed
the local government settlement that i
referred to earlier in the presentation
was for one year only that's only for
2021.22
and the key elements of the reforms to
note are the comprehensive spending
review
and in very simple terms the
comprehensive spending review
determines what the total amount of
public sector expenditure will be
and how much of that pot will be
allocated to local government so one of
the questions will be
how will we compare against the nhs as a
local authority sector
the fair funding review says what share
of the local authority cake
will torrid get so the question at the
bottom of the screen is what waiting for
allocated
district functions such as refuge and
treat cleanses versus social care
so i haven't got the answer to those two
questions but
it'll be a reasonable assumption to do
that the nhs will fare better than local
government
and when you drill down in local
government one would expect social care
to be a higher priority
following this pandemic than refuse
street cleansing the functions we carry
out as a district authority
there's also two other components of
local government
funding reorganization would be the
review of business rate retention and
any replacement for the new home bonus
scheme can i have the next slide please
kirsty
so since 2013-14 um toleration has
retained
40 percent of the business rates it
collects in its area
and along with all of the shire
districts we've done very well out of
business rate retention
that's mainly because uh business rates
have actually grown
we've got low need because we don't have
responsibility for social services and
education
however if you look on that chart the
shy account is done particularly badly
well that's because they've got
high need hey they've got education
they've got social services etc
and they only retain a modest amount of
business rates
so i think it would be unrealistic to
assume that shia districts will be the
beneficiary any changes to
the local business rate we've done well
and the shire counties have not done
well and any
um change to this system of business
rate retention one would
imagine would favor the counties over
the shire districts
next slide please
so what other risk uncertainties
i don't know the longer term impact of
kovid 19.
i don't know the length and depth of any
recession that may be coming and the
increased numbers of people claiming
local council tax support and therefore
reducing our council tax income
i also don't know going forward what
increase empty business rate relief will
be
2020 21 has been an exceptional year for
business
rates and many businesses haven't had
any business rate liability the
therefore not been mindful to claim any
empty business rate relief
the important thing to note is the
council has to bear empty business rate
relief
if you're not being charged business
rates you're probably not too bothered
that your property's empty because you
don't need to claim the empty business
really
this will come out in the wash and that
could be a big cost to the council
i don't know what the collection rate
issues are going to be for the council
going forward for council tax
if people on reduced income or in a
recession it may be more difficult
since um local council tax support has
come in in 2013-14 we haven't actually
suffered a recession
so we're in uncharted territory the
impacts on fees and charges
long term will increase working from
home means less footfall in our town
centres and less parking car parking
income for the council
i know that the government debt's gone
up massively because of the covered
pandemic
there's got to be a day of reckoning and
how that day of threatening comes will
that come through general taxation i
would come from a combination of
increased general taxation and reduce
central government funding
and i don't know how long interest rates
will remain low
i don't have a crystal ball next slide
please
i do have a crystal ball on this slide
however
these are particularly uncertain times
for local government funding with few
certainties over the median term
however it would be prudent to assume
that central government will in
assessing the need assessing the needs
of local government
continue to assume council tax rises up
to the referendum limit
there are the things i don't know i
don't know the scope of the replacement
for
new homes bonus i don't know how torres
will do under the fair funding
review i don't know what the new
business rate retention will be i don't
know the longer-term impact of the
covert pandemic
nobody shared with me the comprehensive
spending review yet
um the replacement of your own bonus was
such a good point that i made it twice
and i don't know the depth of an
economic recession uh netslide please
[Music]
so so as recommendations to full council
are
the torres district council raises a van
d council tax by five pound which is two
point nine
six percent from 168 pounds 66 to 173
pounds 66
and the rationale it recognizes that
council tax is still
the council's most stable form of income
central government's assessment of our
core spending power assumes that the
council tax is increased up to the
referendum limit
it's a responsibility to provide
long-term options for managing
the council's finances and external
auditors will review increasingly so
review torridge's going concern and
financial stability
uh recommendation b is that the council
full council approves the net revenue
budget of 6.956
um that the contribution to reserve
details in 12.4 is approved
and there was a mistake in the report
and a um
update was sent out today uh we'll come
to the slide in a second
kirsten and that the new projects
identified an appendix
cat one the capital report are added to
the approved capital programme if you
just go to the next slide please kirsty
that is a replacement for table that's
at 12.4 in your report that was sent out
a week ago i don't left
it's my mistake completely left in the
table from the previous year
i apologize for that can we um
move on to the next slide please
and i think you've all be pleased to
know that you'll you've stopped hearing
from me and i'll hand over to the leader
of the council and then
the deputy leader of the council thank
you
thank you david um if it's okay
yeah i will carry on okay are you going
to
move that recommendation on page 26 ken
yes i will do i'll go to who i've got to
say first david and then i'll do that
okay thank you thank you everybody
um i don't quite how to follow that
presentation but i prepared some
uh what i prepared earlier as they say i
i think none of us want to increase
council tax that is just common sense
but
there are reasons as david just
explained why we need to
the government does explain us to
actually
um sorry the government the stuff coming
up on my screen
the government expects us to either to
fund stuff ourselves find this funding
or to make reductions and i was going to
talk about the comprehensive spending
review
because we don't know what's going to
happen after this year and obviously
that um is unknown territory as david
has said
so the issue off for councils becomes
raised charges or cut services we are
our our informal get together attended
by 30 out of the 36 members
to give our officers a steer as to what
we think
um in an informal vote we decided that
we would protect our
discretionary services 98 percent of us
voted yes
as that often has the largest effect on
our disaffected members of the
communities
a similar approach to our neighbor
councils are taking
as a council we are facing increased
costs increased demand for services
such as leisure public conveniences open
spaces
support for voluntary groups and at the
same time we're still hoping to invest
in the future
as you can see from the finance manager
report 70
of our households fall in the lower band
of a2c
so the increase will be below five
percent
we only collect for tolerage around
eight and a half percent which is 8.50
in the pod the majority of the money is
collected up by
us us on behalf and the big increases go
to devon county the police and the fire
brigade
but we need to recognize that this will
be hard for many
who have not received financial help or
have lost their job
or reduced hours or unfurlough therefore
we intend to build upon our existing
hardship fund
by bringing forward as some equivalent
to the sentence and allocated to us by
the government
that is to cover anticipated council tax
losses
together with hardship money money from
the devon county council
and other such funds this will be
brought forward to cnr
shortly so we can ensure those families
facing and experiencing hardship this
year
are helped financially as well and
importantly
we make it more accessible for them to
get to that help
i therefore propose that we accept the
recommendations on page 26
a b c and d
as detailed in appendix one that is the
environmental center the leisure
contingency
town hall roof the rolling capital
improvements
the planned maintenance budget excluding
ons recommendations plus note in e
which we've already covered because that
is in the budget anyway
and also adding to that that we will be
pursuing the hardship fund
to help those people most in need so on
that basis
those are the recommendations i would
make and i make those
quite clearly that we recommend on page
26
a b c d is detailed in appendix
one only and not the recommendations
from ons
we know number e because we have covered
that
and we will be adding to that that we
will be progressing the hardship fund
and as i say the a report will come to
cnr
on both the amount of money and the way
that we're going to implement it to make
it much more
um approachable for our members our
community
to get help when they need help so on
that
i'll hand over to my deputy or our
deputy shall i say
the coast of the council claire thank
you
ken thank you
uh councillor james and thank you mr
chairman for allowing me to speak
you've all read my comments attached to
the report so i'm not going to
regurgitate that but first i'd like to
thank and congratulate
the entire entire finance team for
putting together
what has been quite a challenging budget
report for us tonight tonight i believe
we need to agree
the budget recommendations within this
report as
iterated by councillor james we're
required to set a budget
and issue our council tax bills in the
regulated fashion
and within the prescribed time spare
time scales
if we fail to do this we will be putting
the finances of this council
in jeopardy as we will still be liable
to pay
devon county council the police and
crime commissioner the fire service
and the town and parish councils the
amount
that we are due to collect i therefore
second this motion as proposed by
councillor james
thank you thank you very much councillor
hodgson
or have um you do have some questions
and uh i think the first one is
councillor bright
thank you chair uh yeah i'm very sorry
to david but i do have a bit of an issue
with your report
because um the issue with the idea that
cnr have approved the parking charges
when the report clearly states twice
that the
the recommendations will go to full
council so
i know that several members in that
committee did say
that it will be going to full council
all right is there a response to that
please
alright somebody well yes i'm just going
to respond so we're just um in the town
i was just discussing
i'd i actually reviewed counselor bright
my presentation
to um cnr and i've reviewed if you go
to the full council i think it's up um
44 minutes
you'll see a slide that i put up which
says that members of cnr
approve the increased charges and i go
through each
one of those options and increase that
and then on the next slide it says that
cnr
recommends a full council increase in
the council tax i don't know if
tom could put the slides up on
i don't know if you can put the slides
up
so i'm not sure council brought what
in the report though is that yeah
the report i think the report says that
um members of the cnr
approve the increased charges and also
on this slide i mean if we could
wait to see if kirti can get the slide
up council about which may
um sort out any this ambiguity you
believe we have
and you know now you know i've actually
watched back the youtube video
of the cnr and it's quite clear that i
come to and i say
members of cnr approve these increased
charities and i list each one of them
so i'm not sure what i can say there
councillor bright
well that seems a definite model there
because
even the leader of the council did say
that these are recommendations going to
full council
so i you know i'm looking at it and the
first thing it says is recommended full
council the members approve recognition
a to d
and the test that then further down
between after d it says that men would
recommend to full council
a f g and h so very clear why they're in
black and white
so um steve can you uh clarify this
please
um chair i think yes it has has been
clarified as david said
um in david's presentation we're trying
to get the the particular slide
up on the on the screen but uh yeah i'm
having some
technical duties but can't just kirsty
i've just sent you an email with a cnr
slides from the budget i'm not sure if
you can unshare what you're doing
and reshare the cnr one sorry my
ipad won't share tonight chair can i
just come in and
provide some clarification just just um
locating the slides but it is quite
clear
thank you cher it's quite clear from our
constitution the rights and
responsibilities of each of our council
committees
and cnr is responsible for setting the
fees and charges
and full council is responsible for
setting the overall budget
um so actually if the fees and charges
came to full council that that's quite
incorrect
um going alongside our constitution um
so it's always correct that the fees and
charges will be approved by cnr
the overall budget is to be approved by
full council
right but i think the issue is that
confusion is over
recommendation there's a recommendation
um
set in stone as opposed to uh
uh resolved item do you see how i'm
saying you know that
it sounds as i was open for debate a
recommendation to full council as
opposed to a resolved item to full
council
chair the the fees and charges were
proposed and seconded at cnr
and a decision was made by cnr right
but they have delegated power then to do
that so
although it's a recommendation to full
council the decision actually
in reality has already been made is that
right
that's correct the it wasn't a
recommendation to full council in
relation to the fees and charges
cnr um confirmed the fiance charges the
decision notice was published and that
that decision wasn't called in
it's the budget that is coming to cnr
with those fees and charges that are
agreed sorry budget that is coming to
full council
with the with the fees and charges
already agreed by their community and
resources committee
right i understand so in fact then
those car parking charges should have
been called in
to scrutiny then if if somebody wanted
to change them
or some members wanted to change it they
would have had to
have called it in after the cnr meeting
is that right
a scratcher and the decision notice was
published and that decision has been
enacted
um after the five-day call-in period
it wasn't called in so it's been enacted
chair right thank you okay
um that's the bright
i completely disagree because the report
states comes to full council
you can't have this you can't have it
going through the back door there can
you
say you know yeah it says go to full
council and then actually
or we'll agree on the side and not
really do that it is you've got two
conflicting ideas you've got one saying
there's going to full council and then
you've got the other saying you don't
need to
check when i come back in chair i i i
i'm sorry i have to disagree with that
it's not a backdoor decision when we
published a public decision notice
um and it's quite clear from our
contribution
which committees are responsible for
which decisions
and the decision was made by the
community and resources
uh committee that decision notice was
published we left it until the five days
of which overview and scrutiny can call
it in it wasn't
um called in um so i i
i disagree that this was a decision made
for the back door
can i just come in as well i mean it's a
shame that we can't at the moment we're
trying to find the two slides um that to
share with you but also
i have council brought watch back my
presentation
and my presentation to me is perfectly
clear that i'm saying to
this committee cnr recommend that sorry
tnr
approved these charges and i went
through each one
of the increased charges at that and you
know
that was clear i've watched it twice now
my words and
i find it difficult to say to say when
we say it's by the back door because i
feel that
officers have tried their best to be as
open and engaged with the um
members that's why we had a member day
as council james alluded to
um my presentation was you know you had
to suffer it's quite long and detailed
um i hope this i don't know what tom's
getting up now but uh
so i don't i just can't agree sorry that
this is by the back door and as
my colleague um stacy has alluded to we
issued a decision notice saying what
community and resources is approved
right okay so it's all part of a
complete package
recommended to full councils to set the
the council tax so
i think councillor bright that um
there isn't any um any way forward on
this
other interpretation of what uh what the
various committees have
delegated powers to do so i think you're
really your only option is to vote
against if you're not happy with the
situation
but it can't it won't be changed now
am i right and saying that stacey uh
that's that's correct
right okay i've got another speaker um
i think it's councillor bushby did you
put your hand up i did yeah thank you
uh just a question please um on page 20
of the report we've got
uh under rolling program of capital
works
um it says for information the council's
land and building property portfolio
is valued at just under 30 million uh
and we've heard
um david state twice tonight
that the um the value of the or property
portfolio was 38 million
um which is correct please okay can
somebody answer that
please your music david sorry that our
london buildings
uh pop um is 38 million so some of it
will be land um
some will be assets held for sale but in
total um if you ignore our vehicles in
our capital program we've got about
in our audit accounts it's 38 million
right so the report so i mean in
founders some of the bill i mean if you
think about land some of the land we
won't have to say
say the land at the um the golf course
is lo oops
sorry the golf course is located we
won't have to do any um
maintenance on that sorry this
i'm just getting a lot of feed i'm
getting a lot of feedback on myself
apologies
so what you're saying really is that
what's in the report the 30 million
referenced in the
report is different from what you've um
sorry that's fine
i think council plus what i was trying
to explain in saying that in putting
aside 180 000 pounds a year
into our capital to maintain our
existing portfolio of
properties and assets isn't an excessive
amount given the scale of our capital
our portfolio of properties
so i think we've just finally i think
we've finally got the slides up sorry
chair if i can just come back to the
chat yeah
i totally agree with what you're saying
all out the only question i was asking
is it 30 million or 38 million or is it
two different figures
you're muted david oh sorry sorry
counselor i was actually
talking to tom trying to get these
slides up so i might have missed this
subtle nuance of the 30 or the 38
million
so you quote is it in the report at 30.
it says our land and property
land and building property portfolio is
valued at just under
30 million you've referenced you made
reference to that tonight twice
at 38 million i'd have to come back i'll
have to come back to the council
i'm not sure it i think it is 38 million
i'll have to come back to you
it could be just a title yeah i think it
is i'll cook
i'll come back to you counselor possibly
separate i think it is 38 million
okay apologies
all right thank you and now i've got uh
councillor jones
thank you chad i think it's quite clear
tonight after
hearing this presentation that it's
financially prudent for us to put up
the council tax i don't think that we
can
do anything other than that when we look
at the amount of money which will be
lost
in the future if we don't and the result
of that will have on the
on the services which we as a council
provide the only thing i say
is i hope that the leader's financial
hardship program which he's bringing
forward is going to be a robust one
and um is going to be able to provide
support to the people of torridge who
are going to need this
um in potentially the hard times which
are coming ahead of us
i do take issue with one thing in the
report which was a 13.1
where it talks about the car parking
charges and how
people who own the car parking charges
will be
born by people who own cars and
therefore people who own cars are more
affluent than those
who don't i don't necessarily think
that's a
fair assumption to make i think in the
area we live in
yes there are many people in the rural
areas who who cannot afford cars but
many who do
afford who are able to afford cars i
would say are certainly um
not um affluent and i think it's a
little bit unfair to
to look at it in that way um the other
thing which i
um which stuck out to me was on page 31
where we have the
pits we have riverbank house
phase two um and the greenhouse there
i was just wondering in the current
climate with more
working from home seeming to be the the
way forward and what people are going to
want to do in the future
would it not make more sense to
reconsider um
that investment of 200 000 pounds as a
later date when we know what our
workforce would need
um in terms of working from home or is
that something which
is is non-negotiable
um yes yes council jerome thanks so we
are looking
um at our arrangements for staff working
from home
and along with virtual meetings and
everything else
this particular area of work is not
intrinsically linked to that there are
things that need to be done
to river bank house you will recall one
of the
one of the rooms on the first floor
which was formerly used by as a
committee room
has significant problems with the heat
and heating
air ventilation so that needs to be done
alongside which the greenhouse which is
currently occupied by our property team
has reached end of life so what we're
looking to do
is ensure that the staff in that part of
the building have
uh available uh office
space within the rest of riverbank house
so we will
need to have uh less staff working in
the buildings to accommodate
others where part of the building is no
longer fit for purpose or
very close to being no longer fit for
purpose
okay thank you um councillor lock
yeah just one small point of
clarification please on page 14
the last two lines it reads
um the budget management fee paid to
1610
for operating our leisure facilities 128
000
and the mtfs assumes these costs will
rise by 150 000
so does that in therefore mean that we
are going to pay
16 10 278 000 pounds
if they think that recognizes that
whichever way we go forward with leisure
via 1610 via bringing the service in out
or by a new mechanism
that leisure will cost us more going
forward whichever way that will be
we've got to recognize that not
everybody's going to come back
um the social distance in how long that
continues
so that's what it recognizes and how
much we really maybe perhaps should set
aside
for an increase of sort of um
proactive repairs and maintenance
regimes for example
so it's more of a recognition that
leisure going forward is more expensive
i think steve might want to say
something at this juncture yeah and
just uh just to add to david's comments
obviously
uh members we've brought many reports to
you over the last couple of months
around
uh leisure facilities in the reopening
now obviously with the the prime
minister's
announcements today was indicated that
leisure depending on a number of factors
uh may be able to reopen on the 12th of
april
so we will be bringing reports to full
council for you
for you to consider what costs you wish
to debate on the provision of leisure
services
in the district so there'll be a a
series of reports that will be brought
to you
but this is just as david said outlining
that
the it's almost certain that the costs
will will be
increased over and above what we
currently pay
yeah yeah just one final point and i
mean it is our duty to
produce a balanced budget to our
residents and i don't think we have
any alternative but to increase car
parking charges as well as
agreed by and approved by a cnr which i
did sit
and for anyone to say about not
increasing council charge i mean anyone
in the band
is only going to make a difference of
6.41 pence a week
um and with this promise of this new
hardship fund going forward
i don't see you know the two main things
that we have control of
if car parking charges and the council
tax
um i do agree with what council james
and hudson have said so i would approve
the
strategy as well thank you thank you
thank you cancer in laws
right i'm sorry about that um
i didn't like this sort of insinuation
that things were being done
through the back door now it's been
filmed it's been recorded
it's been monitored and i really do
think that the
councillors um some consideration should
be given
to perhaps an apology there i i don't
like to see our officers
being made to look as if they're trying
to push something
through quite a contrary uh that
committee
has the delegation the the the going
through
um council is just a formality the
decision has been made it wasn't called
in
and i didn't like to see our officers
having to justify
uh their situation thank you chair thank
you
councillor coddle honking
yeah just one question um can you
confirm the total cost budgeted for the
new environment center
because you've only spoken about the
increased costs not the total budget
right it's seven million pounds
councillor
just follow up on council locks question
on this page um
14 this figure here for the
um leisure facilities is are you saying
it's going to rise by 150 000 per annum
meaning it's going to
um be 278 000 or something what does it
mean
rise to 158 000 and bring rise
by council of homes so i'm saying it's
going to be like
yes yes right quite a lot isn't it
yeah it is councillor watson
what's the matter chair well you've got
your
hand up for speaking yes no no no
okay so sorry i'm fine i'm enjoying this
oh good that's please you are okay
councillor hodgson
are you wishing to speak no no okay
just counselor chair
well you didn't appear on my screen just
now it's just everybody else cut you
okay carry on thank you chair
yeah i i i was a bit i
i was a bit um amazed with the comments
as well
for against our officers you know
through the back door and all that sort
of comments that's going on tonight
i take action to that because we have
very good officers and i i think
i speak for everybody and they do
they have worked hard over this uh
last 12 months or so over the school 19
period
and you know we we ought to um
congratulate our officers
instead of instead of putting them down
so much
well to be honest i don't think it was
aimed at the officers really it was i
mean it's at the end of the day
us counselors are responsible
responsible for what goes on in council
not the officers they just they provide
the information that we
need i think that um yeah i don't think
there's anything impugning against the
officers at least i hope there isn't so
um i thought so i almost
i hope so as well because you know it
did seem like that
okay um right we've dealt with
the questions now so i'm going to go to
the vote on this
and as you know at cnr i did actually
vote against the budget
but but since then uh council james has
reassured me over the hardship thing and
that's a bit that really
encouraged me to to support this uh
this revenue um budget has put forward
because i think that is the bit that
really will affect us we might have done
very well with the covid
in terms of infection that but we are a
very poor
area and there will be a lot of families
coming forward
who will want relief from council tax so
on that basis i am going to support it
so and i'm going to go to the vote now
so we ready um kirsty
thank you chair councillor belton uh for
councillor brenton four councillor
bright
against council brown
obscene councillor bushby
oh with the exception of the visitor
center at westwood oh
councillor christie oh councillor clark
for councillor cottle hunkin
against councillor craigie
or councillor dart
against councillor ford
against again reference the lovely thing
don't the berries it should be
no resort not a center okay
counselor for
councillor hackett four
councillor haines or councillor harding
or councillor hawkins
against councillor heppell
for councillor hicks or
councillor hudson
councillor hurley or councillor hutchins
or councillor inch
against councillor james
or councillor jones
or councillor langford
for councillor laws or
counselor leather or counselor lock
or counselor manly
or councillor mcgoff
four councillor mackenzie
four councillor newton or
councillor pennington yeah councillor
rossi
four councillor watson
councillor weissman oh
thank you that's 29 four six against
and one abstention chair thank you
councillors
then we move to item seven council tax
resolution and this is a legal bit which
we
it sort of ratifies really what we've
done already a recommendation is on page
41.
i don't think there's any report to go
with this is there um
steve it's as it says
okay so it's as it says it's for as you
said for
formal aces the decision you've taken
with our council tax
and the the council tax precepts for the
other uh precept authorities to enable
us to issue the council tax bills
that's right so we're we're locked into
all these so
um somebody uh can will you move the
recommendation
i'll i'll recommend oh sorry
do you recommend uh
second
all right so just to be clear that was
councilor watson
uh proposed and councillor manly
seconded is that right
okay thank you all right we're gonna go
to the vote on this one
thank you chair councillor belton uh
four
councillor brenton councillor bright
four councillor brown four
councillor bushby or councillor christie
oh councillor clark or
councillor cotter honking or
councillor craigie or that's the dart
again councillor ford
four councillor gov or
councillor hackett or councillor haynes
or councillor harding or
councillor hawkins four
councillor heppell moore
councillor hicks for council hudson or
councillor hurley for councillor
hutchins
or council inch or
councillor james or councillor jones
four councillor langford four
councillor laws four
councillor leather four councillor lock
four councillor manly or
councillor mcgough four
councillor mackenzie four
councillor newton four councillor
pennington
yeah councillor rossi or
councillor watson oh councillor wiseman
oh thank you that's 35
4 and 1 against chair thank you very
much councillors
uh item eight then treasurer management
management report and capital strategy i
think this is uh
housekeeping as well i think it's david
leading on this one yes
my colleague peter hudson will do a very
very sharp presentation so don't worry
too much i think it's only two slides
thanks david thank you everyone um so i
just run through this
quickly so this is the report on
treasury management report and capital
strategy
so the code of practice on treasury
management requires an annual report
on treasury management this is to set
out the strategy for the next financial
year
so we have um appendix form which is the
treasury management strategy
strategy report this sets out the
approach to managing our cash movements
during the next financial year
um appendix two we have our current
current counter parties
um which is basically who we are
authorized to put money with
um in addition the code also recommends
the council set some prudential
indicators
and an mrp policy so appendix 3 has the
prudential indicators in this is how
much we
are authorized to borrow largely for
capital projects
and then we have the mrp appendix before
which is what we set aside to repay our
debt
um along with this the code of practice
also now requires a capital strategy
this is new in recent years this is a
long term strategic plan
policy lincoln asset management plans
and strategic goals
um then the last thing
the last appendix is appendix six now
this arises from members expressed an
interest in
investing in green and sustainable
enterprises
through the income generation working
group we looked at various suitable
options
within within our treasury framework
and then the recommendations was
presented to and have come from internal
overview and scrutiny
scrutiny
hello to update our treasury deposits
um and to prioritize such deposits
um as long as they are meet our current
policy which is
there we are investing with uk banks
which are f1 rated
um the investment period is um meets our
cash flow management requirements
and the interest rate i was is within
0.2
of our of a standard treasury deposit
what that really means in practice is
that
the maximum in interest foregone
investing in a green
deposit is limited to sort of two
thousand pounds per million
um although at the moment that is
probably is probably
negligible due to rates being so low
um so from all of that i think we have
next slide kirsty
um which is the recommendations
uh which is the council approves the
treasury treasury management
and investment strategy and counterparty
list
along with prudential indicators and
minimum revenue precision
um that we update the treasury
management
and investment strategy to prioritize
green treasury deposits
as detailed in appendix 6 and they
approve the capital strategy
right thank you very much peter thank
you
are there any questions i propose on
that
uh chair if you want sorry
councillor newton are we needing to
propose on this one
yes we do indeed yes uh i propose on
that one chair please
thank you thank you secretary please i
was second that j
against a lock thank you very much
um i've got councillor haynes on there
are you wishing to speak
i'm just gonna second it chair thank you
thank you very much rob move to the vote
then
thank you chair councillor belton uh
four
councillor brenton four councillor
bright
four councillor brown four
councillor bushby or councillor christy
oh councillor clark
councillor cottle hunkin or
councillor craigie or
councillor dart
four councillor ford
councillor ford
four thank you councillor dub
four councillor hackett or
councillor haynes or councillor harding
or council hawkins
councillor heppel or councillor hicks
again against councillor hudson
oh councillor hurley or
councillor hutchings or councillor inch
or councillor james
or councillor jones
or councillor langford
four councillor laws or
councillor leather or councillor
or councillor manly four
councillor mcgoff four
councilman mckenzie four
councillor newton four councillor
pennington
yeah councillor rossi
four councillor watson oh
councillor weissmann oh thank you that's
35
four and one against chair
thank you very much councillors so now
we move
to number nine pay policy uh
requirements as you can see there i
think this is really for noting is it
not
um steve jb before you do
um stacy david and i need to
to leave the town hall room and sean
needs to be put in the
virtual room just uh while the leader
presents the report
and that's just in case we decide to
slash or pay by x-men is that right
back indeed
okay thank you right just give him a few
minutes to uh
vacate the premises
well i've got the
all right yeah they've left and i've put
shawn in the waiting room
golly good thank you tom
you're going to do the business on this
one thank you
yeah i i i'll lead and sarah as is
um somewhere in the building or
somewhere and she will back me up
um if there's any questions so simply
this is really for noting
it's a host keeping thing every year we
have to
present this uh form of
table to show um the levels and the
elements of the
remuneration for each of the chief for
the chief exec
and the other um ones that go with it as
you can see from the report
um as far as i'm concerned i've gone
through it
it's been quite a stressful evening so
i'm quite happy
just to ask for members to note um and
they've got any questions i will try and
deal with it or i will ask for help from
sarah
okay uh well you don't need to because
we're just noting it
thank you councillor james uh
had his hand up is that right thank you
yeah it just occurred to me i wonder if
we've got um on the lower echelons of
of pay rather than salary do we have a
living wage policy at this council
because i know
northern war town council does and lots
of other councils
i mean a real living wage or a living
wage which one
i don't know it's called the living rage
there's two
versions um i didn't know that but i
suppose that it would be related to
local levels and
but um yeah somebody answered that
question yes
i can answer that chair so um we
don't pay the living wage foundation
but clearly our salaries
do comply with the national minimum wage
so we do pay above that so the current
national
national minimum wage is 8.72 our bottom
is nine pounds 24
right thank you that clears that one
thank you sarah
any other one if not we just note this
and move on
let's say recorded vote to be taken is
there
well on the screen it says that does it
goodness me
so you're right well thank you thank you
uh councillor bushby
there is a recommendation on page 78
yeah please can we have a proposal
i proposed that i'm so sorry i'll second
it
okay sometimes i will uh
we'll we'll have to we'll take you back
then oh you're quite right you're quite
right i missed that
okay the way we go on the boat please
thank you chair councillor belton for
castle brenton or cancer bright
or councillor brown or
councillor bushby or councillor christie
or councillor clark or
councillor cottle hunking for
councillor craigie or councillor dart
or councillor ford
or councillor galb for
councillor hackett or councillor haines
for councillor harding or
council hawkins for
councillor heppell councillor hicks
or councillor hudson or
councillor hurley or councillor hutchins
or councillor inch for
councillor james or councillor jones
or councillor langford for
councillor laws or councillor leather
or councillor lock councillor manly
four councillor mcgough
four councillor mackenzie
for councillor newton paul
councillor pennington councillor rossi
or councillor watson oh
councillor wiseman oh that's unanimous
chair
thank you so now
just go and get the officers back into
the room
are the questions going to be put onto
the screen um
tom no they were email around to all
counselors earlier to say that
the answers are quite long so they
wouldn't feel yeah
okay fair enough yeah they were they
were long answers it's true hold on to
the one slide so just
okay fair enough
okay the officers are back now chair
thank you very much so now we go to item
10
uh procedural rule 89.
i think the first one is cancer mcgoff
is that right
let's see the first one with a is it his
first uh
question we're dealing with tom yes
the question and answers have been
emailed to all councillors
right okay so uh the supplementary then
um
councillor mcgough yeah thank you very
much mr chairman
um i've been in deep discussion with mr
kearney um in relation to the question
that we all
received and the answers obviously this
afternoon
all i want to note one there is this was
put forward
prior to the it was pre-covered the
first initial motion i raised
um and obviously i would like to accept
the consideration
and that would be debated obviously
following proper procedures not just
through the informal workshop because
this never happened
obviously prior to the budget
implications we go back maybe a year ago
when i first raised this and it never
actually went through cnr on a proper
report
but there's no point in rocking a budget
tonight so i've kept quiet
obviously in the future i'll try again
but i accept the answers by mr kearney
and i have taken a lot of his time up
and i do appreciate it so thank you
thank you thank you councilman golf the
next one is uh councillor james
oh thank you chair yes thank you thank
you whoever gave us full
response um it came out of this
sort of quite a bit of concern locally
um and also northern town council who
wrote to torridge about this
but um planning notices haven't been put
up over the last year in some locations
and there's concern that um this works
against
what's your question though okay sorry
um i'd like to know whether the
um whether it's discretionary or
mandatory that some officers
are unable to go out and put up notices
given that the public can go out and
have their exercise in the open air
and also regarding enforcement situation
um we understood that internal scrutiny
recently that there's a huge backlog in
um
enforcement um so i'd like to know
what effect this is this restriction is
going to have
on this backlog really which i think
probably pre
existed before covid so as two questions
uh
right okay is that is that possible to
answer now if not then
you'll have to receive an answer at a
future date
um i guess the answer to this the first
the first bit is
around essential travel so at the moment
we undercovered restrictions
and we are only able to attract to
travel for essential purposes and to
work
from home the instructions are to stay
at home unless you absolutely
have to travel so that
that side of it was deemed as
non-essential
in terms of the enforcement uh sean
is online and if he can answer that um
today or whether he would need to uh
afford council james a separate response
chair chair i could respond to that if
you like it yeah i i mean i think
forward counselor haynes a
a more detailed response but um
enforcement hasn't stopped
we're making still making some um high
priority
enforcement visits and the enforcement
officers are very busy there's always
been a backlog of enforcement cases
there's more um enforcement reports than
we can
and look at in a timely way or quite
often
but yes i'm quite happy to put a
detailed response to
councillor haynes to supplement the
question thank you this question what
you call essential though isn't it
i mean there was there's a case recently
locally
to me where um a notice hasn't been put
up and
the application has huge implications
for the locality so right
there we are thank you for that yeah
so now there are no under number 11 or
no petitions
12 notice of motion we have two
a first of all from cancer cottle
hunking
yep do you want me to speak yeah okay
your proposer
and secondary well you need to explain
first of all
why you want to bring it forward and
then i'll get a
you obviously propose it or get a
seconder and you're allowed to three
minutes okay
okay yeah thank you okay there are three
budget special meetings held by tdc the
first at cnr
second at ons and the final one tonight
of full council
it would make logical sense for the
first two committees to consider the
recommendations
and for the final debate to be held by
full council even the agenda for cnr had
it written down in black and white that
all of the recommendations are for full
council
but despite it saying this it apparently
wasn't the case
and the decision to increase fees and
charges was made and will not be debated
this evening
as such it had very minimal debate and i
don't believe was considered in enough
detail
which is why i'm proposing this notice
of motion tonight
the recommendations given to the cnr
committee were based on the results of a
poll which asked very simplistic
questions
answered anonymously at an informal
virtual workshop
with a number of councillors absent my
proposal put
forward with the aim to encourage
visitors and shoppers to stay longer in
our town centres
the council has already said they will
freeze the 30-minute parking at 30p
to support local business but if we
really want to support them then we
need people to be staying for longer
either freezing the two-hour rate or
reducing it to a pound would offer
better value
and therefore encourage people to stay
for two hours rather than
the one hour which is most popular this
therefore has the potential to help not
only our town centres
but could also increase the council's
revenue as a result
it's impossible to know for certain but
if someone had a pound on them
and could pay either 90p for an hour or
a pound for two hours
i would say it was likely that they
might stay for longer
a number of people tried to send in
letters to public participation at
tonight's meeting
but unfortunately the council declined
to read them out so here are a few
snippets
catherine wopshot chair of torrington
chamber of trade
tdc needs to support local businesses in
opening up after code
19 for the social and economic benefits
of vibrant high streets
not impacting their chances at recovery
with increased costs
frankly many businesses are on the edge
of survival in 2021
and this increase is the opposite of
what torrington and its traders need
first city bright local town trader i
feel any increase would have a
detrimental effect
particularly after the difficulties for
everyone in the last year
locals and visitors alike john eels
currently on the town's futures group
heritage trail map and website
the exiting of all the boats and issues
of the post office
already aggravates a growing problem
chasing motorists for more money to park
in town
will not make up then you presumably
seek
yet lead to the likely reduction of
income over time when all the retailers
close now is not the time to tinker with
these charges
i think these points have been sent in
sum it up really
and i urge councillors to support the
notice of motion
to allow the consideration of the
current decision in more detail
for the benefit of our commun
communities and town centres thank you
thank you a secondary secondary yeah
who's that margaret margaret brown mr
brown
speak yes thank you um
i support um and second councilor
hankins
uh motion great torrington has lost
thanks
ms andrew noticed that post office will
close in march
but what we have not lost is our
community spirit and pride
in our traditional shops and way forward
small towns have been hit hired by
combat 19 and we need all the support it
can get
and we as a council need to help to
revitalize once the shops are open
shoppers and visitors also to browse
and and see what torrington has to offer
spend time perhaps in spanning market
when it's opened
more more people are now turning into
food banks and relying on family credit
and going out of town free car market or
turned into the internet
so i firmly support everything council
hunting has said
and i hope that this council will
support too thank you
thank you well clearly this would
do uh cnr
so uh is there any i'm just checking to
see this
well there's no uh no further the debate
on this
that's a presentation made by the
proposer and secondary so we will go to
the vote on
it going to cnr which is obviously where
it should go
so i was just going to say chair uh it's
the decision of the council if it goes
to full co
if it goes to cnr not that it should go
to casino
there's the decision tonight of whether
the council feels
that we need that to go to cnr well
well that's why we're taking the vote if
ocean falls then
it goes nowhere right
councilman against
councillor brunson abstain
counselor bright four
councillor brown laura councillor bushby
i'm staying counselor christy
against councillor clark
against councillor qatar honking
for councillor craigie
against councillor dart
abstain counselor ford
four councillor dub
abstain
councillor hackett again against
councillor haynes against
councillor harding against
council hawkins
four councillor hepple
against councillor hicks
against councillor hudson
against councillor hurley
councillor hutchins or
councillor inch
councillor james against
councillor jones four
councillor langford four
council of laws against
councillor leather
against thank you councillor mcgoff
against council mackenzie
abstain councillor newton
against councillor pennington
h councillor rossi
abstain councillor watson
james
councillor wiseman against
thank you
so that's eight four twenty one against
and seven
abstentions chair thank you kristy
notice falls so we go to b then which is
from councillor bright
and do you want to uh lead on that
please count sprite foreign
secondary uh thank you chair uh first
i'll declare
interest as i buy a residence payment
and a business partner
i'll bring this motion to full council
because uh i
like councillor honkin agree that the
recent changes in parking charges
support neither residents nor our local
businesses
i think car parking is always a
contentious issue as we've already seen
this evening
um in the past we debated temporary free
parking in torridge
over several uh months and going through
numerous meetings
to decide a plan of action but even so
it seemed even more troubling that we
seemed to allow this to slip under the
radar without sufficient debate
uh that aside the the cnr
uh meeting approved and increased the
parking charges by 50
per hour over the next three years uh
this will hardly be an incentive for
customers to go back to the high street
and support our local businesses
especially if we compare this with the
large chain stores who offer free
parking
they often have to offer a greater range
of hours
and who are often um not nearly as
affected by the pandemic as our local
homegrown businesses
are we do this simultaneously
while increasing the cost of residential
payments by 50
uh many residents currently face a 20
pay cut due to being further
as if they were fortunate enough to have
kept their job
uh we're expecting the covenants and
restrictions will be listed very soon
um many businesses will be returned to
operation after a two month break
both businesses who have been forced to
close through lockdown
as well as those businesses who had
taken reduced takings because of the
restriction
and how do tourists go about supporting
this by increasing the business permit
by 54 to 406 pounds 90 p
at the end of the three year period and
businesses have got
the finest funds from somewhere now
while many businesses at the minute have
received a government grant this year
uh available to fund this from that
that funding pot but it's unlikely those
grants are gonna last for the whole
three years
while torridge continues to rise its
prices
the recent change in parking charges do
balance the books the torres district
council
but it does seem that we have failed to
consider the financial strain on many of
our residents
are feeling as a result of the pandemic
and we appear to have misjudged
the need to support businesses in our
own
country or as our own country comes out
of lockdown
so i am ending my notice of motion
slightly
i propose that we do not change the
parking charges in biddeford great
torrington or holdsworthy
car parks as proposed by the recent cnr
committee region
and that we continue to use the parking
charges for those towns which were in
place previous to that decision
while we review the parking charges and
permit charges
that is carried out
with a view to reducing the burden on
the residents and local businesses
we could partly fund this using the
surplus which was created in recent
budgetary changes
as is stated at the members event where
it was
where we were more than enough that we
made changes more than enough
to cover our intended projects
right okay well you you have amended
your
notice of motion there um point of order
chair
was he allowed to do that um
yeah sorry well
it it it used to be the case that you
could have met you could amend your
notice of motion it's true
um but providing the secondary would
agree to that
second that who's the seconder counter
hutchings
answer hutchings right so you you heard
the amendment
or well it actually was an addendum
actually to uh
what bright look forward to notice a
motion did you did you
support that you said it okay
so do you wish to speak councillor
hutchins um very quickly
um just say i have several issues with
car parking charges increasing in
different areas and i would just like to
see it be reviewed so i just call on
other councils supported going to cnr
for another discussion
um hopefully it wouldn't affect the
budget too much but i'll just
let it have a discussion or a further
discussion so that's why i'd ask
councillors to support it
right okay well clearly uh we we have no
facts or figures tonight to uh
to put any um price tag attached to
these
two notes of motion the first one's lost
in any case but
this one will go to the vote uh
chairman i've got my hand up sorry oh
there's no discussion cancer wrench
if it's a point well i just i just want
to
register my interest really oh
okay i i have an interest because i
i i buy a season ticket each year
okay okay so i should be abstaining
i just wanna
yeah thank you for that yeah that's
quite right that's quite right there's
noted
your interest okay so we'll go to the
vote then
thank you chair councillor belton um
against
councillor brenton jane
councillor bright for councillor brown
or councillor bushby stone
councillor christie against
councillor clark against
councillor cottle honking or
councillor craigy or
councillor dart
abstain counselor ford
four councillor gov
abstain councillor hackett
against councillor haynes
and sorry was that against
okay against thank you
councillor harding against
councillor hawkins paul
councillor heppel against
councillor hicks against
council hudson against
councillor hurley against councillor
hutchins
councillor inch councillor james
against
councillor jones boar
councillor langford for
councillor laws
councillor leather against
councillor lock against councillor manly
against councillor mcgoff
against councilman kenzie
abstain councillor newton
against
councillor pennington
councillor abstain
councillor watson or again
sorry councillor wiseman
against
so that's 9 4 20 against and seven
abstentions chair thank you very much
kirsty
well councillors we've um managed to get
through one of the most
um do every year which is to uh
set a budget which uh nobody likes to be
putting the rates up that's for sure so
we managed it so thank you very much for
your time
sorry councillor christie's raised his
hand
oh really okay point of order is this
councillor christie
it's just out of interest actually this
popped up on my news feed
just minutes before this meeting and
it's very interesting in terms of what
we've just been discussing
parking charges in some north devon car
parks this summer
are set to be hyped to cope with the
expectation that demand for holidays
will be so high
north devon council strategy and
resources committee are being
recommended
to charge an extra 40 p per hour on some
of their coastal car parks between april
october
so it looks like um apple door and
westwood are going to pay you for the
rest of toro john
all right okay well they did they just
said there was like a
lot of heavy cooking on for
accommodations
not just say church church feels that
busy
i absolutely agree they shared a burden
let's earn some money
no no it'll be it'll be full of jet ski
people who are there with their trainers
no room for cars church fields
they'll be swarming down well thank you
very much councillors we'll
see you again shortly for the officers
as well and members of the public have
managed to